these people are trying to find whatever
is left in their destroyed homes
this Rubble was once up to razak
Hassan's house now he feels he may even
lose this if he fails to find the title
Muffy
no one helped us no diggers excavators
or machines but he stayed under the
rubber for days we lost so much now I
have to find the title deed to prove
this was my home
genres with a population of 18 000
people was the worst hit town in
Northwest Syria from two earthquakes
struck earlier this month
the devastation is absolute more than a
thousand buildings here have either
collapsed or been heavily damaged
hundreds of people died and thousands
were injured
the survivors are now trying to cope
in this isolated rebel-held area they
can only rely on International Aid
many students here are served only one
meal a day and many receive even less
they say they don't receive enough
International Aid and it is poorly
organized
Leila Suleiman has lost dozens of
relatives and friends she says her
family has been displaced several times
it was rainy and cold I
have days on the street we got this tent
it's not for winter it's tiny kids can't
sleep during the night because of the
cold I want nothing just a proper tent
for my kids
the impact of the earthquakes left many
families shattered here
their faces better the weight of loss
and devastation
many syrians here tout they had survived
the worst after enduring 12 years of
Civil War and conflict but now in the
aftermath of the earthquakes they have
lost even more their homes possessions
and sense of security
most syrians here have spent years
running away from the war
their only dream a normal life
earthquake will hit again anytime we
just set up a tent here and are living
in it nowhere is safe now
people here say most lives were lost due
to a lack of modern rescue equipment and
now an absence of Aid food and shelter
is worsening their misery
Al Jazeera genderes Northwest Syria